20 seconds and counting
humans have always been explorers
as a species we are innately curious
about what lies beyond our horizon
if the day ever comes when we embark
across the cosmic oceans beyond our moon
what vessels will we use to discover new
worlds
few art projects capture the wonder and
awe of voyaging to an unfamiliar planet
better than the explorer series
brought to life by incredible digital
artist christian grievsky the story is
set in the distant future where the
remnants of humanity journey to a lush
exoplanet called ion the ongoing
explorer project doesn't just examine a
vibrant alien ecosystem but also
documents the fascinating vehicles the
early explorers used to chart the
unfamiliar planet so for this entry into
the archive we'll tag along with the
first wave of explorers and voyage
across this mysterious world in a range
of different machines and as always you
can follow and support the artist using
the links in the description
now let's set off towards planet ion
we set out from planet earth on the oria
the greatest construction project in
human history and after a brief journey
of
317 years we arrive
to explore planet ion up close we must
leave behind the safety of the
mothership
landing on the planet's surface for the
first stage of our expedition we'll be
traveling in the ant a compact research
vessel that will make exploring planet
ion safer and more efficient
setting off from our landing site it's
not long before we spot our first life
form stooping for a drink in a shallow
creek are unique bipedal herbivores
they're tall over two and a half meters
or nine feet and have an elegant
appearance like earth deer they seem
rather skittish bounding across the
terrain as we pass by a few of them
stand their ground not interested in
abandoning their prime watering hole
using their two lower horns they begin
to produce a rattling noise that seems
intended to frighten away predators
but perhaps it isn't us these deer are
scared of emerging from the underbrush
or the first predators we've seen on
this planet these are the silent death
and they are built for the chase
like cheetahs their aerodynamic bodies
are capable of incredible bursts of
speed
similar to many life forms on ion the
silent death lack eyes instead relying
on sonar-like echolocation soon a chase
will begin between predator and prey a
drama known to most planets with complex
life
driving through a marshy swamp land we
can spot a rather singular looking life
form these bizarre herbivores are a
member of the forminus kaput
a taxon marked by the sizable holes in
the middle of their skull getting a
closer look at this alarming gap we can
see the hole serves as an enormous
olfactory organ with sensitive hairs
giving the creature an incredible sense
of smell
an extreme yet effective anatomical
feature with their long snouts and
tongues this species somewhat resembles
an anteater the exact function of their
tongues isn't known but likely helps
them snag their preferred food source
from the swampy water
yet in this marshland sticking your
tongue in the water can be dangerous
from the murky depths a menacing
predator lifts themselves on two
muscular arms with a length of 11 meters
or 36 feet this semi-aquatic life-form
is the largest carnivore we've seen so
far like the alligators or crocodiles of
earth these patient hunters ambush their
prey from the water drowning them or
swallowing them whole their snake-like
bodies make them excellent swimmers and
their strong arms paired with their
spring-like musculature allows for
explosive movements passing near the
water's edge is a risky venture
yet one titan in this watering hole pays
little mind to what lurks below the
surface
this is a stag beetle rhino and they
spend their days combing through the
swamp in search of tasty vegetation
curiously their breathing organ is at
the highest point of their tail helping
them stay underwater for longer strange
as that might sound various earth
beetles breathe through sphericals in
the rear of their abdomen when plodding
through the swamp stag beetle rhinos
used two antennae on their backs to
create whip-like sounds that warn
predators to keep their distance for no
species wants to end up on the receiving
end of their horn
for the next stage of our tour we'll
need to travel in something that can
handle all manner of terrain the monkey
is a futuristic research vehicle
suitable for the most challenging
environments and will take us into the
teeming forests of this alien world and
speaking of monkeys in the branches
above us are the ion equivalent of
primates the odellion is a somewhat odd
looking herbivore that feeds on the
foliage of the high canopy like the
woolly monkeys of the amazon rainforest
moving from branch to branch is second
nature to though delion this field
sketch shows the odellion's method of
traversing the canopy a locomotive
strategy that might look backwards to us
but serves them well curiously the
odellion seems to lack teeth altogether
instead opting for long muscular lips a
trait that helps them pluck leaves off
the high branches
deeper in the forest from the bank of a
forest stream a brightly hued creature
is watching us this is a toxicurum a
midsize predator with highly poisonous
skin like the vivid colors of a sea slug
the toxicorum's coloration is aposomatic
warning other predators against taking a
bite and if a toxicorum subdues its prey
they drink their victims internal liquid
using their tentacles we're fortunate to
be behind protective glass
among the flooded roots of the forest is
an exceedingly rare gathering these
bizarre creatures are mania capets and
there are just a few thousand of them
left on this planet their giant heads
can make a deep drumming sound when
threatened and house highly sensitive
receptive organs typically solitary the
mania kaputs will call out to each other
over thousands of kilometers during
breeding season and come to congregate
in forests like this one we're lucky to
be able to observe such an infrequent
ceremony but it's best to give them some
privacy
in a dense region of the forest a
standoffish looking creature blocks the
path of our vehicle this is a turtleneck
a solitary lifeform that despite being a
herbivore is an aggressive bully that
doesn't tolerate intruders
like rhinos turtlenecks will charge any
life-form they deem a trespasser two
shield-like protrusions protect the
sides of their body and seem to envelop
their heads these shields can change
from soft and flexible to hard and rigid
in an instant allowing the turtlenecks
to ram into their targets at high speeds
without risk of injury our best move is
to take the long way around the
turtleneck's territory
in a nearby clearing a small flock of
bipedal omnivores hiss at our vehicle as
it passes these pint-sized creatures
resemble alien chickens although instead
of a beak they possess a muscular hole
for a mouth surrounded by four frenzied
tentacles like earth shorebirds these
generalists scavenge often for food
they've become unexpectedly fast little
creatures in pursuit of small insects
that are the alien chicken's favorite
food which this field sketch illustrates
to aid in this endeavor their tentacles
are sticky and act like flyswatters
bringing insects directly into their
gullet
to chart the next region we'll be
traversing in crickets lightweight
helicopters capable of vertical takeoff
and landing
try to stay close for we're passing
through an area home to the largest
megafauna on this planet
looking up at us as we pass overhead is
a herd of boneheads these bellowing
behemoths possess a triangular hole in
the middle of their head that serves as
an olfactory organ marking them as
another member of the forminus kaput
classification like hippos the boneheads
have evolved to spend most of their time
partially submerged in water which helps
support their significant bulk connected
to the bonehead's hollow skulls are
flexible fishing rod like trunks they
use to catch aquatic life forms for the
boneheads are omnivores feeding on all
manner of underwater organisms to stay
satiated
turning westward we can spot a noisy
procession of circulus another type of
forminess caplet their circular head
gives them the ability to make a unique
loud call the distorted shape of their
skull amplifies the noise although the
result is a face that looks rather
unusual by our standards the circulas
also possesses two tentacles that they
use for smelling navigating their
environment with their keen olfactory
senses
not far from the circular procession a
group of clumsy and colorful looking
bipeds slurp from the muddy water these
are angus columns and they are on the
small side for this region at about 1
meter or 3 feet these omnivores might be
unassuming but they feed in a somewhat
unsettling manner as this field sketch
shows the anguis columns use their long
tongues to dig into muscle-like
creatures then blow poison into them and
wait until their soft tissue becomes
liquid a disquieting way to get a meal
although nature is often unforgiving
snow and harsh winds block our path to
the north so we'll hitch a brief ride in
the massive frog a mobile research lab
that moves on wheels over 14 meters or
45 feet high in a vehicle like this
we're ready for anything and it seems
we've attracted the attention of
something equally massive
this inquisitive giant is called a
gantor and they seem puzzled but not
particularly bothered by our presence
here at nearly 25 meters or 82 feet in
length gantors are an incredible species
to witness up close yet even more
impressive than the gantor's sheer size
is their remarkable intelligence gantors
possess two trunk-like appendages that
play an important role in their
communication
during mating season they seem to use
their tongue for some kind of sign
language to impress and talk to their
favorite partner
exactly how intelligent gantors are is
difficult to ascertain but it's possible
we've just made first contact with
something very special
to venture further out into the unknown
we'll be taking to the skies once again
in lightweight aircrafts called geese
don't let their unusual shape fool you
these crafts are fast and agile enough
to get us an up-close look at the rarest
life forms
trumpeting at us while we pass overhead
is a herd of what appears to be alien
elephants yet what seemed to be large
ears from a side view are actually
massive bone structures surrounded by
soft muscle tissue their unique skull
also contains a large hole marking them
as another member of the forminus kaput
classification
like the circulars this unique head acts
as a powerful sound amplifier for the
thunderous calls of these alien
elephants holes they can use to connect
over vast distances for unlike the
social elephants of earth these curious
creatures spend much of their life cycle
all alone
landing for a moment to stretch our legs
we make an unsettling discovery
not far from our position or three situs
mortems the most dangerous hyper
carnivores on planet ion the aerodynamic
shape of these terrors allows them to
make tight turns when pursuing a target
in reach blazing speeds like earth
tigers their efficient musculature helps
them take down prey many times larger
than they are yet unlike tigers these
predators hunt in coordinated packs and
with the strongest bite force on the
planet the situs mortums have no natural
enemies our best move now is to get back
in our vehicles and fly in the opposite
direction
back in the skies once more we pass over
a valley home to the single largest land
animals on the planet this is a herd of
tortugantis creatures that from tip to
tail are over 100 meters or 300 feet in
length witnessing a tortigantis is like
seeing a god walk upon the soil of a
planet with such massive bodies the
tortugantes herd spends much of their
days finding food mainly in the form of
vegetation herds like this one can
contain up to 50 individuals and are
remarkably close knit as the intelligent
tortigantes are capable of feeling
empathy for their fellow herd members
for the final and most spectacular leg
of our journey we'll be traveling in the
top of the line hornets these vessels
can travel vast distances without
stopping which is important for we'll be
flying over the planet's ocean
on the rocky coast a somewhat unusual
group pays little attention to our
passing crafts these are snail frogs
agile and rather playful omnivorous
creatures their upper and lower body
have sail-like structures which seem to
be used to make snail frogs look bigger
to predators and to impress fellow
members of their species
like earth snails snail frog stock eyes
are capable of 360 degree rotation and
they give the species a distinctive and
somewhat amusing looking appearance
snail frogs primarily feed on
mollusk-like creatures in shallow tide
pools which they scratch from the rocks
using their powerful four-part jaws
moving out to sea we can spot our first
group of fully aquatic lifeforms
swimming just under the surface chasing
a group of fish analogs are the
triangulous stingray pursuit predators
with slim aerodynamic bodies like earth
stingrays they possess barbs capable of
producing venom yet the triangulus
stingrays possess three forward-facing
barbs instead of one in the rear which
they use to spear their prey with their
triangular wing shape these hunters can
stop almost immediately or change
direction when pursuing a meal
further out to sea a larger more
terrifying creature dwells in the depths
up to 11 meters or 35 feet in length
these predators prefer to hunt in the
colder reaches of planet ion nicknamed
alien seals these lifeforms are swift in
the water like earth seals however when
it comes to land they can't do much but
flop about some say these alien seals
look quite peaceful when lying on the
shore although this site is difficult to
imagine considering how menacing they
look when prowling the dark depths we
can be glad we're not in the water
yet the air doesn't seem safe either a
flock of huge flying creatures soared
just beyond our hornets these are red
deads and with a wingspan of almost 30
meters or 100 feet we might be in
serious trouble
yet despite a name that suggests
aggressive behavior red deads are
actually quite peaceful while from time
to time they do have aggressive fights
with rivals hence the nickname these
majestic beings aren't here to pick a
fight with us like dolphins accompanying
earth boats red deads are naturally
inquisitive and are flying alongside
their new airborne mates out of sheer
curiosity little else is known about
these beautiful red beings although
given their size they likely have no
natural predators
soaring alongside this flock is a
special privilege
yet our voyage is not over yet breaching
near the surface are the final life
forms we'll be observing on this tour
this is a family of emanus cetacea the
largest living moving creatures yet
discovered on this planet dipping under
the surface in an underwater pod we can
see that like baleen whales these
leviathans comb the oceans with their
giant mouths and eat everything that
comes their way yet at over 110 meters
or
360 feet in length they make even the
largest earth whales seem rather small
in the unspoiled oceans of ion families
of amanecetatia lead calm and peaceful
lives and as incredible as it's been to
get close to the species we don't want
to disrupt said lives
the time has come to head back
journeying through the ecosystems of
planet ion has been fascinating you can
discover more of the incredible vehicles
featured in this video in christian
grievsky's explorer art book which i've
got a link to in this video's
description there are big plans for this
universe as grievsky is working with
other creatives on a novel and a
screenplay and is also releasing a
second art book that will focus on the
creatures and the narrative of this
exciting world to stay up to date on the
project follow and support christian
grievsky using the links in the
description i'm excited to see where the
project goes next
and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you